[Musique]
bienvenue dans l'essentiel le magazine
qui reprend toute l'actualité de la
semaine au département tout de suite
l'actualité en chiffres la commune de
saint-andré dispose désormais d'un
nouveau centre d'incendié et de secours
les 37 sapeurs pompiers professionnels
ainsi que les soixante sapeurs pompiers
volontaires ont pris possession de ses
nouveaux locaux
un investissement de 2 millions neuf
cent vingt neuf mille euros financés à
hauteur de 80 % par le département et de
20 % par la commune de saint-andré le
département a mis en place un vaste plan
de construction de nouvelles casernes
fois le sist la réunion en partenariat
avec les communes et aujourd'hui je suis
heureux d'être à saint-andré pour
d'inauguration de cette occasion devient
une 9 millions d'investissements une
case yens tout ne vous accueillir sur le
personnel justice ici à saint-andré le
plan khazen la constitution de
l'occasion ne fait partie de cette
volonté de donner de meilleures
conditions de travail aux personnels de
justice la réunion ils sont 200
courageux à prendre le départ du trail
de la chaloupe 23 km de course entre
forêt littorale avec un passage proche
du conservatoire national botanique de
mascarin est vrai qu'à saint leu on a
vraiment une chance parce que ya toute
une histoire à raconter et par exemple
cette maison elle a aujourd'hui deux
tours avec une belle façade de warrants
mais il faut imaginer qu avant 1800
c'était simplement un poste de vigie de
tout on passerait régis pourquoi pour
surveiller la rade canda sur saint leu
et au moment de la guerre des anglais
c'était l'occasion justement pour
pouvoir ensuite général
après saint pierre et cilaos saint-andré
la troisième commune a signé la
convention du pacte de solidarité
territoriale avec le département
ce dispositif vise à soutenir le
développement des 24 communes de l'île
le département prévoit une aide de 90
millions d'euros disponibles sur une
période de trois ans la commune de
saint-andré prévoit plusieurs chantiers
dont la réfection du chemin du centre de
l'avenue de la république et une série
d'action sociale pour un budget
avoisinant les 13 millions de vies c'est
pas que représente tout simplement un
partenariat très fort entre la commune
de saint-andré et le département
moi je crois qu'on ne peut pas
travailler les uns à quoi à côté des
hommes
je veux travailler les uns avec les
autres
il sera donne de la cohérence à l'action
publique et à saint-andré je sais que le
maire et son équipe ont beaucoup d'idées
il y a plein d'actions menées dans le
domaine social et d'un domaine de
l'aménagement le département et auprès
du maire et de la des élus de
saint-andré de la population de
saint-andré pour le mieux vivre
cha cette commune de l'est donc on peut
dire trois axes embellir la ville
améliorer la nuit et rassembler le plus
possible de gens en allant au devant de
l'aide de ces personnes pour qu'elles
puissent participer à la vie de la
société
[Musique]
les vingt-et-une femmes sapeurs pompiers
du service départemental d'incendié et
de secours de la réunion se préparent à
défiler sur le barachois pour ce 14
juillet elles sont au centre de toutes
les attentions car mis à l'honneur
elles défilent en tête du cortège suivis
de leurs collègues masculins 80 sapeurs
pompiers professionnels volontaires et
jeunes sapeurs pompiers
j'ai déjà participé à quelques un défilé
du 14 juillet avec mais c'est la
première fois dans une section
pour moi c'est une fierté de représenter
les filles ça tu connaissais les femmes
pourront le formidable de notre société
elles ont pu jouer mais encore plus
maintenant et la femme d'aujourd'hui
elle est totalement épanouie et elle
s'épanouit dans les métiers des armes et
militaires mais aussi dans les métiers
civile comme le disque eh bien je salue
leur engagement pour une fois je les
félicite et le département accompagne le
stis dans cette profonde mutation
le bonus de cette semaine c'est les
images du défilé de ce 14 juillet comme
chaque année beaucoup de visiteurs ont
tenu à assister au défilé des troupes et
des engins sur le barachois
[Musique]